very impressive could could another way
to address the potential class-based
speciation be the education of the child
and by the principles of let's say that
over the last hundred billion people
that have lived and died to build this
beautiful world we live in today with
all the food and water ubiquity and the
governments and the economies that there
every child that's being stamped out
into this world might have a little tiny
missing chip on their shoulder and that
missing chip might be things like their
parents explaining to them what
evolution is or what their
Anatomy what their heart and their brain
is their body maybe what morality is
things like that if maybe every child is
born with a little bit of something like
that do you think there's something like
that Jordan gevis you know like that's
done right
this thing
connecting everyone to everything and so
the probability that people are going to
be get whatever education they want in
the next 30 years is overwhelmingly high
so I think in some sense
that problem is being solved as rapidly
as it can possibly be
being solved that is doesn't mean people
should stop trying to find more and more
effective ways of educating I think that
would be realized there's some general
basic principles that you think a parent
should teach a child but obviously
within the rules of life but it may be
something about evolution or something
about their own Anatomy and well I think
that I I think that there are all sorts
of things that parents who are good
parents teach their children I mean part
of what twelve rules for life is about
is about that's like a universal ethic
in some sense there I think that there
is a there's dawning realization among
members of the biologically oriented
community let's say that there is
something like an emergent ethic that's
evident in biological systems I think
one of the most outstanding examples of
that I would say is apart from the work
that DeWall has done with chimpanzees
showing the beginnings of an ethic
at least in the behavioral sense the
beginnings of an ethic among chimpanzees
is work that's been done with rats and
so yog panksepp for example who wrote a
book called effective neuroscience which
I would highly recommend it's a real
work of genius you mean my mind with
Piaget by the way with the way that rats
well--that's panksepp that was no Piaget
found that out found that out in
children so Oh panksepp was the
scientist who discovered that rats laugh
and you think well that's not a big deal
it's like actually it is a really big
deal because it shows that it shows
commonality of the positive emotion
systems across biological strata
essentially so it's actually a really
big deal and he found that if you tickle
routes with an eraser they laugh
ultrasonically yeah so you have to slow
it down to hear them and the reason he
would figure that out was because he was
trying to figure out why if you take rat
pops away from their mother and feed
them and give them enough water they
still die so they die unless you massage
them with well he used a pencil eraser
that's what because it's kind of soft it
seems to work without harming the rats
little rat pops and if you rub them with
pencil eraser then they'll thrive and
that was actually translated very
rapidly into practical research because
it turns out that if you have a
premature infant it's in our incubator
they often lose weight a which is a
really bad thing because they're
supposed to be gaining weight but if you
massage them 3 times a day for 10
minutes then they'll gain weight about
as fast as they do in utero and they
leave the hospital on average 5 days
earlier and the beneficial cognitive and
physiological effects are still
detectable six months down the road to
walloping it's a walloping effect and so
it turns out that one of the things
panksepp sorted out was that human that
touches a human need it's not a
secondary need it's a primary need like
like food and water the childhood
development yeah yeah well and he was
also a big proponent of rough-and-tumble
play because he found out that in rats
that rough-and-tumble play especially
among juvenile males catalyzes
pre-frontal development and that rat
pups who are male that aren't allowed to
engage in rough-and-tumble play show
prefrontal hypo development and you can
then treat them with Ritalin
which is the ADHD drug just in case
you're wondering so that's a very dismal
line of scientific research but also
very promising
so what panksepp also found and this is
another piece of information that really
blew me away when I first first read
about it was so he he banks have
discovered the play circuitry in mammals
and that's also a big deal right that's
like discovering a continent to discover
a dedicated circuitry to a set of
complex biological functions that's a
big deal man and so when he was
exceeding play behavior among rats he
noticed that juvenile males in
particular would work to wrestle and
they wrestled really a lot like all
human children or like cuman children
and dogs wrestle and rat spin each other
so what Pink's have found first was that
and other scientists as well but I'll
use him as a shorthand was that rats
would work to enter a play arena where
they knew they were going to be allowed
to wrestle with a appear and that's kind
of how you figure out if a rat wants to
do something right you make him button
press for it or pull on something and
then you can measure how fast you press
the button or how hard a poll and you
can get some estimate of how motivated
he is and that's pretty damn motivated
to enter into a play arena and so if one
rat enters into a play arena and another
rat does and the one rat is ten percent
bigger than the other then in like nine
out of ten cases the big rat can pin the
little rat and in the first bout then
pinning establishes dominance this is
kind of an interesting commentary on
scientific methodology too because let's
say that you are investigating rat
behavior and you were trying to draw
conclusions and you only paired rats
together once you'd assume the big rat
dominates its physical size that does
the domination and that's the purpose of
play but that isn't right because
finally what it went of relates as well
play is something that iterates right
you don't play with a person only once
you play with them well who knows for
how long right if it's a relationship
that lasts decades then it's decades of
reciprocal interaction so panksepp and
his colleagues and the other scientists
who are working on this paired the rats
repeatedly so these are iterated games
and the rules of an integrated game
aren't the same as the rules of a
off-key and that might actually be the
basis for a universal ethic is that
there are rules for iterated games and
what banks have found was that ok so the
big rat is now super ordinate to the
little rat
now when you repair them the little rat
has to ask the big trout to play that's
the rule so the big rat gets to sit
there like he's cool and the little rat
has to hop up like like a dog that's
asking you to play and sort of bounce
around you all know what that looks like
dog kind of puts his rear end up in the
air kind of hops a little bit and that
means like well come on human not me you
know and if you have any sense you know
how to do that and and you can even
understand when the dog does it and the
dog if he socialized can understand when
you're doing it right because a well
socialized dog is you kind of you kind
of go like this and then he does the
same thing and you whack him on the side
of the head a little bit he growls and
puts his you know your hand in his mouth
but he doesn't bite it but he sounds
like he's going to the dog knows what
the hell's going on unless it's
completely unless it's raised by a
behavioral psychologist which is the
worst behaved dog I ever saw was a dog
that was raised by a behavioral
psychologist okay and so anyway sorry
about that but so anyway so you pair
these rats together and what you find is
that so the little rat has to ask the
big rat to play in the big rattle like
you know break is cool and then wrestle
and then if you pair them repeatedly
unless the big rat lets the little rat
win 30% of the time the little rat will
no longer ask him to play like and I
read that it was like little electrical
storm went off in my bag is what
happened to me - well it's so good so
I'm so absolutely unbelievable is that
well there you have it emergent ethic of
reciprocity all you need to do is pair
animals together in reciprocal play
boats and you have an emergent
reciprocity and then you think well okay
so that's the basis for social
interaction is that reciprocity there's
a bit of an advantage to thee to the big
rat but not a huge advantage say well
that's the beginning of an ethic and you
say well human beings that ethic emerged
at the biological level and then human
beings watched it develop and told
stories about it that's where the
stories came from and then out of the
stories we coded and explicit ethic and
that's where the philosophy of ethics
came from but it emerged from the bottom
up something
you predicted 150 years ago he said well
you know we'll find that there was an
emergent ethic that emerged biologically
and then was later mapped and so that
was just well that's just absolutely
beyond belief didn't move very likely
true and points the way to something
like
while an archetypal ethics certainly one
of reciprocity which I think the
fundamental archetypal ethic it's like